après ce quart entre rue de la mare est
aujourd'hui très haute à l'étang des
salines à sainte anne les spécialistes
les amoureux de la nature ne sont pas
surpris par ce phénomène
il précise qu'il intervient 2 à 3 fois
de l'année à la marée d'équinoxe
c'est quand la lune se trouve au plus
près de la terre donc à phénomènes
magnétiques ou donc les a c'est la
période de l'année où aller plus au fond
auprès de marie a dit que l'écart de la
basse et la haute marée est le plus fort
donc c'est ce qu'explique ce qu'on voit
d'ailleurs là que l'eau est vraiment
monté et apathique partouche est le
soubassement du platine en arctique ont
un avantage qu'ils environ une
soixantaine de centimètres au cours de
ces périodes le marnage plus attendre 80
85 cm x men à 90 cm et donc on a bien
entendu logware qui va remonter beaucoup
plus loin à l'intérieur des terres
beaucoup plus loin à l'intérieur des
étangs des lacs etc
et donc c'est vrai que ça peut avoir des
incidences sur la fin lors de l'incident
est plutôt positive ce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier que quand il apparaît si vous
voulez au niveau de la mangrove
elle sert à quoi elle va pénétrer à
l'intérieur de la mangrove
elle va apporter donc de l'oxygène des
sels minéraux mais elle va aussi appelé
à se retirer
épuré la mangrove et donc repartir avec
toutes les impuretés qui se soit
produite dans la mangrove une période
favorable à la reproduction des
différentes espèces de crabes appelé en
martinique des séries qu de c'est ma
faute ou encore de mantoue très apprécié
des amateurs une saison les hommes en
tout cas par cas gavin walls voyous
c'est la période où selon les mots tout
sur tout comme l'as de l'eau les crabes
sauter 10 euros bobbies
une période où vous pouvez être surpris
par une brusque montée des eaux sur la
chaussée comme le dit si bien les
anciens
la nature reprend toujours ses droits et
nous rappelle que les mangroves joue un
rôle très important dans les clips de
l'écosystème et servent notamment d'abri
à de nombreuses espèces telles que les
crustacés les poissons les muscles mais
également oiseaux alors plus que jamais
respectons notre mans